at around half 2:00 in the morning this
quiet neighborhood in Andover was shaken
awake the moment was caught on Joshua
Howard's home security cameras here's
how he described what happened next we
were completely asleep and the sound was
just so loud like I can't even
comprehend like how loud it was but to
me it was like a car crash like massive
collision we just like jumped out of bed
and you know felt a bit shaky you know a
workshop is there aftershock the
explosion off it was just because I've
woke up too quick the two end properties
in a row of Terrace homes had been
completely destroyed I look out the
window and there's just rubble rubble
everywhere and so then we rush out the
house all six of us and the dog and then
yeah we just we just turn around and
it's just gone number one has just
completely folded in on itself number
two is not you know not much better and
yeah it was just really shock you don't
really have to do in that situation
nothing really prepares you for that
situation amongst the rubble was the
body of a man as emergency teams
meticulously combed through what was
left of the homes trying to piece
together what might have happened people
in neighboring properties were kept away
for their own safety
concentration at this point is to make
sure that people who can't return to
their homes this evening have got
somewhere to stay and have some
certainty about where they can stay
until such time as they can return home
it's a devastating time here for this to
happen
obviously many people's Christmases have
been disrupted awfully by this and
that's why it's so important that we
make sure that we can find them at
alternative accommodation quickly
throughout the day gas engineers have
isolated the supplies to the properties
here the supplier sgn gas says it's too
early to speculate about what's gone on
here but that it's working closely with
emergency services to try to identify
the cause for now only eerie reminders
left behind give a sense of the homes
that once stood here Katie Spencer Sky
News